inflation currently on the rise more and
more people are showing up to places
like this catholic charities to seek
help i just think it's affecting
everybody right now obviously
everything's super expensive giancarlo
tells me he comes from a single income
household and right now times are hard
it could get difficult so
yeah i mean it just everything is very
very high right now forcing him to seek
local resources for help with essential
needs i've never
had to get any type of assistance never
thought i would but i mean you just got
to do what you got to do right like
getting help from food pantries like
catholic charities the food pantry is
probably where we see the highest impact
because that's the first that's really
the first line that people hit
particularly with inflation that's
hitting their pocketbooks with gas and
food making getting assistance something
steve schmidt says you shouldn't be
embarrassed about we're all in this
community together
you will probably come down and see
families from your neighborhood
in that line so there's no shame in it
because sometimes we all need just a
little bit of help it's not just
affecting one individual is affecting
everybody maybe pushing the ego to the
side for a bit just think of the big
picture jeremy j ford live local now